JONES' REPORT, HE IS CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF COVID
VACCINE AND THERAPY MAKER
PFIZER.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
HOW CONCERNED SHOULD PEOPLE WHO
ARE FULLY VACCINATED RIGHT NOW
WITH THE PFIZER REGIMEN BE ABOUT
THIS NEW VARIANT?
>> I THINK I AM CONCERNED BUT I
AM NOT IN PANIC AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN PREPARING
FOR A MOMENT LIKE THAT FOR THE
LAST TWO MONTHS AND I THINK WE
ARE NOW REALLY, VERY WELL
PREPARED TO -- TO WIN THIS
BATTLE.
>> SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, AND
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO BE PRECISE.
WE DON'T WANT TO OVERSTATE OR
UNDERSTATE THE SITUATION, THE
DANGER.
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT THE
CURRENT PFIZER VACCINE WILL
PROVIDE LESS PROTECTION AGAINST
THE OMICRON VARIANT?
AND WHY WOULD THAT BE?
>> A CHANCE THIS WILL HAPPEN AND
WE WILL KNOW IN TWO, THREE WEEKS
AND THE MORE TIME PASSES, THE
MORE DATA ACCUMULATE ON CERTAIN
SITUATION.
BUT AS I HAVE SAID, I DOUBT THAT
THE RESULTS WOULD BE THAT WE CAN
FIND OURSELVES THAT WE ARE NOT
PROTECTING AT ALL.
WE CAN FIND OURSELVES THAT WE
ARE PERFECTLY FINE AND WE ARE
PROTECTING AS HIGH AS WITH THE
DELTA.
OR THAT WE ARE HAVING A LESS
PROTECTION WITH -- COMPARED TO
THE DELTA.
AND IN BOTH CASES, BOOSTERS
SHOULD REDUCE DRAMATICALLY.
>> AND AT WHAT POINT -- I MEAN,
AGAIN, THIS IS ALL VERY NEW EVEN
IN SOUTH AFRICA, THOUGH IT IS
NOW THE DOMINANT STRAIN THERE.
UM, YOU'VE SAID THAT PFIZER
STARTED THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
FOR A NEW VACCINE TAILORED TO
OMICRON.
CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN IN -- I
MEAN, I'M -- I'M THE WORST
SCIENCE PERSON AROUND SO CAN YOU
JUST EXPLAIN IN LAYMAN'S TERMS
HOW THAT WORKS?
AND HOW SCIENCE -- I MEAN, HOW
IS IT THAT YOU ARE ALREADY ABLE
TO BE WORKING ON A VACCINE THAT
SCIENTISTS ARE STILL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT ABOUT IN SOUTH
AFRICA?
>> THERE ARE FEW THINGS THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE VACCINE.
BUT THERE ARE FEW THINGS THAT WE
KNOW FOR CERTAIN.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT IS GOING TO
BE MORE VIRULENT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO
TRANSMIT FASTER OR HAVE HIGHER
DISEASE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT WILL ESCAPE
THE PROTECTION OF OUR VACCINES
BUT WE KNOW THE SEQUENCE OF THE
VIRUS.
WE HAVE.
AND THIS IS HOW EVERYTHING
STARTS.
WE START [ INAUDIBLE ] ON FRIDAY
BASED ON THE SEQUENCE A DNA
TEMPLATE THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
MAKE -- PUT INTO THIS VACCINE.
IF A FEW WEEKS FROM NOW, WE
REALIZE THAT WE DON'T NEED A
VACCINE LIKE THAT, THEN WE WILL
PUT IT IN A CELL.
A BETTER, SPECIFIC TAILORED
VACCINE BUT NEVER USED BECAUSE
WE ARE PROTECTING BETTER WITH
THE CURRENT VACCINE AND DELTA
VACCINE BUT WE NEVER USE FOR THE
SAME REASONS.
SO DOING THE SAME WITH OMICRON
RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL NOT HAVE WASTED ANY
TIME.
>> SO, YOU -- SO YOU PUT
RESOURCES INTO DEVELOPING A
VACCINE FOR DELTA WHEN DELTA WAS
RISING IN THE THOUGHT THAT IT
MIGHT -- IF THAT BECAME THE
DOMINANT STRAIN AND THE CURRENT
VACCINE DIDN'T WORK, YOU WOULD
HAVE THAT READY TO GO BUT YOU
DIDN'T USE THAT?
>> EXACTLY.
AND THE SAME.
EXACTLY THE SAME.
>> SO, MODERNA'S CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER SAYS HIS COMPANY IS ALSO
DEVELOPING AN OMICRON-SPECIFIC
BOOSTER THAT WOULD TAKE TWO TO
THREE MONTHS TO GET INTO TESTING
AND THEN PRODUCTION.
YOU SAID PFIZER COULD DO THE
SAME 100 DAYS OR LESS.
IS THAT A WINDOW THAT CAN BE
NARROWED DEPENDING ON HOW THE --
THE WORK GOES?
>> I THINK, LIKELY, WOULD BE THE
WINDOW BECAUSE WE HAVE MEASURED
IT TWICE ALMOST TO THE DAY.
THIS MEANS THAT AROUND 60 DAYS
ON THE DEVELOPMENT, WE WILL HAVE
CLINICAL PRODUCTION OF A VACCINE
SO THAT WE CAN GO AND TEST IT IN
HUMANS.
AND THEN, WITHIN 95 DAYS, WE
WILL HAVE THE FULL RESULTS OF --
OF THIS TRIAL.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT IS THAT
IF WE HAVE THE VACCINE AND IT'S
NEEDED AND IT WORKS, WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO TRANSITION
MANUFACTURING TO THIS NEW
VACCINE WITHOUT LOSING ANY
SINGLE DOSE -- ALMOST ANY DOSE
FROM THE CURRENT CAPACITY.
I REMIND YOU, RIGHT NOW, WE ARE
AT 1 BILLION DOSES.
THIS IS HOW MUCH WE PRODUCE THIS
QUARTER.
WHICH MEANS NEXT YEAR, EASY 4
BILLION DOSES.
I THINK IF WE HAVE TO GO TO NEW
VACCINE, WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE EASILY 4 BILLION DOSES
FOR THE NEW VACCINE.
>> UNTIL EVERYONE AROUND THE
WORLD HAS ACCESS TO VACCINES,
THOUGH, WE ARE ALL -- EVEN IF
WE'RE -- HAVE FULL REGIMENS HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, WE ARE
STILL GOING TO BE VULNERABLE TO
MUTATIONS B
MUTATIONS, CORRECT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FIRST OF ALL, IN A -- IN A
PANDEMIC, YOU ARE AS PROTECTED
AS YOUR NEIGHBOR.
NEIGHBOR DOWN THE ROAD BUT ALSO
THE NEIGHBOR IN GEOGRAPHIC
SENSE.
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE IS GETTING ENOUGH
VACCINATION BECAUSE VACCINATIONS
IS THE PROBLEM.
>> THE DISTRIBUTION.
ALBERT BOURLA, I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND WORK
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
MORE ON THE MEDICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH DIMENSIONS NOW.
JOINING US FOR THAT, CNN CHIEF
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT, DR.
SANJAY GUPTA.
ALSO, DR. LEANA WEN, CNN MEDICAL
ANALYST, FORMER BALTIMORE HEALTH
COMMISSIONER AND AUTHOR OF
"LIFELINES, A DOCTOR'S JOURNEY
IN THE FIGHT FOR PUBLIC HEALTH."
SO, SANJAY, WE JUST HEARD FROM
MR. BOURLA.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU ABOUT
WHAT PFIZER IS DOING AND ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE AT?
>> WELL, THERE IS A LOT WE STILL
DON'T KNOW.
WE ARE SEEING THE SCIENTIFIC
PROCESS UNFOLD, REAL-TIME, ONCE
AGAIN.
I THINK THERE -- THERE WAS A
COUPLE THINGS THAT SORT OF
JUMPED OUT.
IT WILL BE A COUPLE OF WEEKS AT
LEAST BEFORE THEY CAN TELL JUST
HOW WELL THE VACCINES PROTECT
AGAINST THIS PARTICULAR VARIANT.
THAT TAKES TIME.
SOME OF THAT'S LABORATORY
STUDIES WHERE THEY WILL TAKE
THIS VARIANT, OMICRON, PUT IT
IN -- INTO A -- A PETRI DISH
WITH THE VACCINE AND BASICALLY
SEE HOW WELL THE -- THE
ANTIBODIES NEUTRALIZE THE VIRUS.
THEY ARE ALSO GOING TO BE
FOLLOWING REAL-TIME DATA IN
HOSPITALS AND TRACKING CASES AS
THEY ARE IN SOUTH AFRICA.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE DOING THAT
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
BUT THIS IS JUST GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME.
I -- I THINK WHAT I -- WHEN I
HEAR ALL THESE COMMENTS FROM
THESE VACCINE MAKERS, I THINK
ONE OF THE CONSENSUS IS THAT
THERE IS PROBABLY PROTECTION
THAT IS STILL OFFERED CERTAINLY
BY THESE VACCINES.
SO, THEY'RE STILL VERY
EFFECTIVE.
THE BOOSTER WOULD MAKE THEM EVEN
MORE EFFECTIVE BECAUSE YOU ARE
GENERATING MORE ANTIBODIES.
BUT THIS -- THIS VIRUS APPEARS
TO BE DIFFERENT, AND MAY REQUIRE
A -- A DIFFERENT BOOSTER AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE.
>> DR. WEN, THOUGH, I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, ONE SCIENTIST IN SOUTH
AFRICA WHO RAISED ALARMS ABOUT
THIS HAD SAID THAT THE CASES SHE
HAD SEEN WERE -- WERE MILD.
UM, DO WE KNOW YET HOW WORRIED
WE SHOULD BE?
I MEAN, DO WE KNOW WHAT -- OKAY.
THERE'S A NEW VARIANT AND, YES,
IT'S GOT ALL THESE ATTRIBUTES
THAT ARE VERY CONCERNING.
B
BUT DO WITH KNOW YET WHETHER THE
ACTUAL -- SOMEBODY WHO GETS ILL
WITH IT IS WORSE OFF THAN THEY
ARE WITH DELTA OR SOMETHING
ELSE?
>> WE DON'T, ANDERSON.
THERE IS SO MUCH THAT WE DON'T
YET KNOW ABOUT OMICRON.
BUT THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW THAT MAKE US WORRIED.
FOR EXAMPLE, HOW TRANSMISSIBLE
IT APPEARS TO BE IN SOUTH
AFRICA.
ALTHOUGH, WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THAT'S GOING TO PAN OUT IN THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
WE ALSO DON'T KNOW ABOUT IMMUNE
ESCAPE, AS SANJAY WAS JUST
SAYING.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THIS QUESTION
OF IS IT CAUSING MORE SEVERE
DISEASE?
OR IS IT GOING TO CAUSE REALLY
MILD ILLNESS?
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT I THINK THIS IS WHY THE U.S.
AND MANY OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING WHEN IT
COMES TO PREPARING FOR THE
WORST.
WE WOULD MUCH RATHER DO THAT
THAN THE REVERSE BECAUSE FOR SO
LONG IN THIS PANDEMIC, WE HAVE
BEEN DOING THE OPPOSITE.
WE HAVE BEEN WAITLING FOR
SOMETHING TERRIBLE TO HIT US.
WE WERE CAUGHT OFF GUARD WITH
THE DELTA SURGE.
I THINK IT'S MUCH BETTER IF IT
TURNS OUT TO BE A FALSE ALARM
AND WE DID ALL THE PREPARATIONS
AND IT TURN OUT NOT TO BE A BIG
DEAL BUT ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
THINGS IT COULD HELP WITH IS
MAYBE GETTING BOOSTERS OUT, FOR
EXAMPLE, COULD HELP US TO STEM
THE DELTA SURGE.
GETTING PREPARED IS EXACTLY THE
RIGHT THING FOR US TO DO AT THIS
POINT.
>> SANJAY, CAN YOU JUST GIVE US
KIND OF THE LONG VIEW IN THIS?
BECAUSE JUST HEARING THIS, I
MAIN I THINK LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE, WHEN I HEARD THIS NEWS I
JUST THOUGHT, YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS
LIKE -- YOU KNOW, RELATIVELY
SPEAKING, THINGS WERE GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THEN THIS THING COMES ALONG.
BUT AS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT,
UNLESS EVERYBODY GETS VACCINATED
AROUND THE WORLD OR HAS ACCESS
TO VACCINES, I MEAN, THIS CAN
JUST DRAG ON FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS WITH -- WITH NEW
MUTATIONS OCCURRING.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, VARIANTS ARE
LIKELY TO KEEP OCCURRING AS THE
VIRUS CONTINUES TO TRANSMIT.
THE MORE IT TRANSMITS FROM
PERSON TO PERSON, THE MORE
MUTATION MAY OCCUR BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE ALL GOING
TO BE POTENTIALLY PROBLEMATIC
MUTATIONS, EITHER.
THERE IS ALSO THIS POTENTIAL TUG
OF WAR AS THE SOUTH AFRICAN
HEALTH MINISTER WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS MORNING AS VIRUSES
BECOME MORE TRANSMISSIBLE,
EVOLVE INTO BECOMING MORE
CONTAGIOUS, SOMETIMES THEY LOSE
SOME OF THEIR PUNCH AS WELL.
THEY TRADE ONE OFF FOR THE
OTHER.
SO YOU MAY SIGH THAT.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE KNOW, THIS
IS, AGAIN, UNFOLDING REAL-TIME.
THE SPECIMEN THAT WAS COLLECTED
THAT ENDED UP BEING THE FIRST
SPECIMEN THAT WAS ON NOVEMBER
9th SO, YOU KNOW, JUST THREE --
THREE WEEKS AGO OR SO.
AND IT WAS IDENTIFIED TO HAVE
THIS GENOMIC SEQUENCE.
WE NOW KNOW IT'S IN 15-PLUS
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD AND
THERE'S SOME 50 MUTATIONS ON
THIS.
SOME OF THESE MUTATIONS, WE HAVE
SEEN BEFORE AND THEY WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH MORE
TRANSMISSIBILITY.
OTHER MY TUTATIONS WERE ASSOCIA
WITH A HIGHER CHANCE OF ESCAPING
THE IMMUNITY.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE A 3D
IMAGE WE CAN JUST SHOW THIS REAL
QUICK.
IF WE HAVE IT, YOU CAN SEE THE
SPIKE PROTEIN OF THIS VIRUS AND
YOU CAN SEE ALL THESE VARIOUS
MUTATIONS ON IT.
AND IT GFIVES YOU AN IDEA OF WHT
SCIENTISTS ARE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH IN TERMS OF IDENTIFYING --
THAT'S IT.
THE SPIKE PROTEIN AND THESE ARE
THE MUTATIONS WITH THIS
PARTICULAR VARIANT.
THAT'S -- THAT'S THE 3D
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT THEY ARE
BASICALLY TRYING TO DEAL WITH
AND ADDRESS, ANDERSON.
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT I AM
LOOKING AT.
I MEAN, I'M SUCH AN IDIOT.
I -- I -- I WISH I UNDERSTOOD
SCIENCE BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, THAT LOOKS -- YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT IS A SPIKE PROTEIN AND
IT'S GOT ALL THESE DIFFERENT --
DIFFERENT MUTATIONS ON.
YEAH.
IT'S -- IT'S -- IT'S A LOT THERE
BUT THE POINT IS THAT YOU
HAVE -- WHEN YOU HAVE THAT MANY
MUTATIONS ON SOMETHING, IT -- IT
CHANGES THE CHARACTER OF IT
QUITE A BIT.
DO THOSE MUTATIONS ADD UP TO
SOMETHING THAT MAKES IT EVEN
WORS